Turning to chapter 2, advanced problems, problem
number 10 asks this seemingly innocent question.
Find the number of subsets of the set 1 up to 2000,
the sum of whose elements is divisible by 5.
That might take a little moment to parse, but to illustrate let me
show it on a much simpler example, where we have the set 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
This has 2 to the 5th, or 32 distinct subsets, which look like this.
If you compute the sum of each of those subsets,
and you organize them by which ones have the same sum,
you'll see that 8 of those subsets have a sum which is divisible by 5.
So the answer here would be 8.
The case with all the subsets of 1 up to 2000 is obviously way,
way bigger, and you might be able to guess at a rough estimate for the answer,
but the challenge is to compute the exact answer.
I really love this problem, and the full video I did on this question
covers a really beautiful and surprising way you can think about it.
It uses one of those tools that mathematicians keep in their
belt that legitimately feels like magic the first time you see it.